now this is some liberal [ __ ]
you don't know his life situation she
didn't go to Harvard okay stop [ __ ]
trying to make excuses for him using
stolen Harvard Valor he didn't go he
can't sit with us if you think that
women are so [ __ ] dumb then all you
gotta do is say I went to Harvard and
then they'll be sucking all over your
dick well you might catch one or two
little guppies but guess what someone's
gonna [ __ ] say you cry across the
table from you one day and be like you
didn't actually go to Harvard Sweeney am
I the [ __ ] for serving my sister's
husband dinner using toy utensils
that's hilarious that's [ __ ] funny so
y'all took this guy's side saying he's
not an [ __ ] how come well who's it I
didn't respond you said no he's not an
[ __ ] she did no there's probably a
more tactful way he could have done this
okay but like the whole like Ultra
machismo shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
hi welcome back it's me Gina and Tiff
and Jess hi look we're back doing my
favorite thing judging people so we're
gonna do uh am I the [ __ ] because we
need more episodes of just doing this
because Jess's opinions are fun yes
um so I pulled a bunch of uh article I
mean um uh topics link or threats
threads and posts from like the
subreddit am I the [ __ ] and we're
gonna judge people and tell them if
they're [ __ ] or not and you guys are
free to also comment in the comment
section uh if you agree or not and why
all right the first one is am I the
[ __ ] for not caring for a child I
said I wouldn't care for huh
[Music]
it's the last episode our brains are
fried uh am I the [ __ ] for not caring
for a child that I said I wouldn't care
for okay
um I am a 20 or 28 year old female and
I'm Child free I don't even really like
kids yes
in the house
[Applause]
um the house down
[Laughter]
um it's [ __ ] funny my uh my 23 year
old sister Amber has a kid and because
it's a pretty close-up family she's
pretty used to everyone pitching in to
help she said she was going out for a
few hours I'm stopping by my house to
pick up a package delivered to me by
mistake we have the same street number
or similar sounding house streets
um so it happens pretty often when Amber
got to my house
sorry this is [ __ ] flying Tim is
trying to kill a gnat yeah it's been
bugging us all day I know so I caught
one last night so my um ego is pretty
high about that yeah sorry very
confident can you start over it's fine
um so Amber has a uh has a daughter who
has a child and um the sister Amber was
going to stop by and pick up a package
that was delivered to me by mistake
because our house numbers and streets
sound very similar
um when Amber got to my house she put
down her kid and said thanks for
watching and by the way I asked her what
is she talking about she said she was
thanking me for watching her kid I said
that I never agreed to it and was not
okay with it but she said we're sisters
family helps family and end up leaving
she just volunteered her baby so she
could go run some errands so I didn't I
left the kid right in my entryway where
Amber left him and just went about my
day
I started to be on her side but no
I didn't leave the house or anything but
I said I'm not a babysitter and I wasn't
one okay well she didn't leave the house
never better but still but yeah hold do
we have any had a kid because it's
pretty close I mean it has to be still
in a car seat yeah probably it just
literally sat there all day it didn't
cry she didn't hear it crying I don't
think she cared oh my god well it breaks
my heart I didn't leave the house or
anything but I said I'm not a babysitter
and I wasn't one well Amber got mad at
me when she came back four hours later
and the kid had a full diaper and was
crying when we saw her when he saw her
she was gone for four hours she was the
kid was left out there for four hours
it's crazy I told her I was outside
yeah okay I thought it was like outside
like the front door no like kind of like
in your hallway where all your mailing
shoes are she basically left the kid
over there for four hours when she knew
her sister didn't want to take care oh
my God I hate this Mom I told her I said
I wasn't watching her kid and she's
lucky I didn't call the police but Amber
said that not wanting to babysit doesn't
mean you don't do it the entire family
sides with her and Amber says she's
cutting me off until I apologize and
make more of an effort with my nephew
I've gotten nasty messages from
relatives Galore and uh and the only one
who doesn't think I'm a raging [ __ ] is
my dad who doesn't involve himself in
family drama I do love my sister and
understand family is family but am I
really the [ __ ] for not doing a job I
expressively say I didn't want to okay
this one's a little both of y'all are
[ __ ] annoying yeah
[ __ ] race you two so first of all I was
on your side yeah you ruined that yeah
so let's go and wheel that back
um
your sister [ __ ] up and left her baby
at your house but you don't leave a baby
in the foyer for four hours he's [ __ ]
crazy
have you guys seen that new show uh
called honey that is uh Jessica Beals in
it Jessica Biel so she ends up
portraying like a true story of this
lady that ends up killing her friend or
whatever so anyway she kills this mom
and leaves the baby crying in her crib
for hours and hours yeah the baby was
crying for so long that her little voice
was was like horse yeah and that her
diaper she was literally filled in like
her crib was yeah species and like that
scene we recently saw it maybe like this
I'm traumatizing it was traumatizing for
me to see that scene like that stuck
with me and like hearing that baby cry
in the show like it was just a show like
it was a [ __ ] show but that scene
stayed with me and like see like here
hearing that is like taking you back to
that scene and I'm like traumatized all
over again like that poor baby so
innocent yeah like there's no reason to
be neglected like I don't like kids
either but I would [ __ ] sit there
with a little toy or something and
[ __ ] deal with it until the mom came
back and then been like don't ever
[ __ ] leave her baby here again you
know I don't want to [ __ ] watch this
kid I had to sit here and like make cute
faces for hours you know how much that
took out of me yeah don't ask me to do
this [ __ ] again yeah yeah but like you
don't [ __ ] ignore it yeah that's
absolutely important that's cool you
don't ignore the baby I don't know the
baby's pronouns
you don't know the baby's pronounced
because he has he or she hasn't told us
yet
that's so [ __ ] like it's cruel yeah
that's cruel your sister's Beyond that's
beyond being an [ __ ] yeah yes that's
being [ __ ] inhumane yeah
[Music]
wait the the sister that was so not
Amber not the mom or hold on sorry I
can't get this out who threatened the to
call the cops the mom or the sister the
sister okay because the mom could have
been to college yes I mean not really
but the neglect yeah four hours that's
the sister that didn't watch the kid is
the one who said she was gonna call the
cops on the mom yeah I understand that
okay but I'm saying because that kid was
under her care whether she wanted to or
not she's the adult
I'm saying there could be a case for
neglect no because the mom left her I
fully agree the mom definitely is as
well 100 of the time oh as well for them
yeah but I'm saying the ant here
that was yeah for four hours with the
the full diaper crying like yeah there
should be consequences there that would
be furious like your sister is dumb but
you're a [ __ ] dude yeah that's [ __ ]
up
I would have fought her if I was it's
like she's trying to I mean yeah I just
I I really don't understand why the
sister thought she could just come over
and drop the baby off yeah that's dumb
you can't just assume your baby
the kid is not probably well taken care
of gonna have a you know like to because
like if if I if you were like hey Jess I
really need I I really need a sitter and
I'm just like I really don't want to
watch this baby like would you really be
able to go off with your dad you were
worried you would be worried just
[ __ ] you'd be like oh my God I was
gonna happen like I can't no oh [ __ ]
what am I gonna do I couldn't like you
know are more important without like
really feeling like this person wants to
take care of my baby will take care of
my baby do everything they can to make
sure my baby is like in the safest
[ __ ] place yeah for this thing that I
have to go do like nothing nothing would
make me leave my baby somewhere and say
how entitled that's [ __ ] crazy no how
entitled do you have to be to [ __ ]
assume that you're just gonna dump a
baby on someone that's gonna take care
of it for you and especially when they
explicitly said they won't right and
then that's her sister she should know
how her sister how she is yeah and then
if the whole family's against her who
the [ __ ] else didn't she try to go like
drop the baby off at an auntie someone
else yeah they're all [ __ ] pissed at
her yeah I mean I get it I get it she
[ __ ] up hardcore she's a total [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] she deserves to be
like kicked in the kicked in the butt
cheeks a little little but tooth won't
hurt
to be violent but you know yeah that's
absolutely ridiculous yeah she's 100
worse than an [ __ ] yeah but so is her
stupid ass sister yes especially a
stupid ass sister [ __ ] kid or Mom
whatever we want to refer to Amber
stupid ass Amber for the kid so top
comment is everyone sucks here you left
a baby unsupervised for four hours no
matter what point you're trying to prove
are you really willing to risk the life
of a baby to make it that's ridiculous
the only good solution here was to tell
her you wouldn't take care of the kid
and tell her that if she leaves you'll
call the police then you call the police
if she leaves yeah you don't let a kid
unsupervised for four hours even if your
sister sucks you don't leave him forever
if I really like hated like I'm like I'm
not [ __ ] watching this baby you're
not [ __ ] walking out on me yeah like
that's neglect like if you just leave
your child somewhere that's the case for
CPS yeah so like you didn't even bother
doing that you just let the kids sit
there you both deserve to [ __ ] go to
jail that's exactly what I'm saying that
the sister has neglect charges yeah
potentially whatever I can't speak but
it's also like not even her
responsibility for sure you know so it's
just [ __ ] up it's ridiculous yeah and
then if she threatened the cops why not
do it and then have the cops take care
of the baby
oh I'm just so annoyed everyone sucks
here there isn't a better way for two
adults to handle a situation than to
leave a diaper wearing toddler alone on
a porch for hours
I wish I can call the cops on both of
you yeah
um why the hell do you not call the
police yeah she's an [ __ ] for not
asking you sure but you are a huge
[ __ ] for just leaving a helpless
child defend for itself like that I'm
actually kind of curious to see if this
girl actually responded yeah is there
any op responses at all let me see if
they don't don't doesn't it get shut
down I feel like that I've seen that a
lot like if the original poster doesn't
respond to like the comments oh my God
so she's justifying down no she's
justifying herself um let's let's hear
her justification yeah she said the
child was in a car seat carriers
carriers that the Lisa didn't get out I
think the kid isn't walking yet so
probably wouldn't have gotten too far
but I wanted but wanted to be safe
and then people are just like four hours
hungry and what in a car seat your
sister's an [ __ ] but you are too no
compassion for an innocent baby she also
goes and says a poor child the baby was
one years old my entryway is indoors
um
there is there was no kidnapping risk
unless someone broke into the house
um and she said thank you for your input
I see that on several replies here um
but where I'm living there's a high
chance that if I call the police they
would take her child away it's something
you do as a last resort I don't think
what my sister did was good parenting
but not quite on that level calling them
but leaving the kid for four hours yeah
dude is not or like it's better than
calling the the police and having her
sister learn a lesson about leaving her
kids with people that don't want to take
care of her kid yeah imagine it wasn't
her sister this time imagine it's just
some friend oh yeah I'll take care of it
yeah some friend with a creepy boyfriend
perhaps is this lady not [ __ ] think
about where she leaves her her children
so sad her cousins like imagine like the
amount of times that kids have been left
watched with someone who shouldn't have
[ __ ] been in that house I just know
why that triggers me so much why because
I forgot that that was literally my
childhood getting left with all kinds of
babysitters and [ __ ] all kinds of
babysitters yeah also being left alone
locked in the bathroom yeah for hours
and actually not once it happened
multiple times because I remember one
time there was a kid or a Kidder a
litter of kids
yeah a litter of kittens was one time
another time I was like playing in front
of the mirror for hours but it was like
when you like went into a different
dimension yeah yeah when I thought when
I thought I might have gone into my
dad's drugs or something because like I
was tripping balls in the bathroom yeah
I remember tripping balls but yeah like
I think that's what that is why I get so
yeah I got left with a bunch of random
babysitters too for sure
it's not a good experience yeah but yes
um everyone agrees that both of them
suck but that [ __ ] is [ __ ] awful
uh the next one is I told my daughter
she can live with me with this condition
I 34 year old male had a child 10 years
ago her name is Nova I was a terrible
person back then I didn't stay in her
life and I deeply regret it a few months
ago I contacted her mom to see if I can
see my child she happily agreed to
co-parent with me and seemed relieved
which was understandable considering she
had four other kids all younger than
Nova Nova was a bit disinforce but now
we are doing better she is generally a
very good kid but something I realized
about her is that no punishment seems to
work on her and also she can be very
disrespectful at times how old is this
kid again 10. okay if I tell her to do
something as punishment she won't do it
or if I ground her she'll just leave
without my permission
I asked her mom how she punishes her and
she says she has never punished her
before what I've heard from novas it
seems that she would just cuss her out
and yell at her which I don't think are
good punishments for a kid two nights
ago Nova asked me if she can live with
me from now on I told her I told her I
loved her but she can live with me with
one condition she has to follow my rules
and be respectful she didn't say
anything after that after she went back
to her mom's home my mom who was there
when Nova asked me this told me I was an
[ __ ] because if a kid is asking her
deadbeat dad to take her in there must
be something very wrong so you don't
make conditions with her you just say
yes and you take her in was I really
wrong to have this condition I can't be
a parent if she doesn't listen to me but
now both my mom and daughter refuse to
talk to me
her mom will likely have no problem with
this she seems too busy with the other
kids and thinks she would like being
alone on the weekends anyways and I
think she would like being the weekend
fun parent so that's not really a
problem I I don't think he's the [ __ ]
I think he just maybe is not quite aware
of what's really going on so he had
there's an edit he added I took Nova out
for some ice cream and asked her why she
wants to live with me she said I don't
want to live with you anymore you're
just gonna send me back anyways I
apologize to her and told her that I
would never send her back and I would be
very happy if she lived with me I just
want another reason after talking for a
while she said I just want to sleep
turns out after she started coming to my
home her mom gave her bedroom to her
younger sisters one of them is a baby
and they cry all night keep her awake I
told her I will talk to her mom and she
will stay with me from now on and that
we're gonna have some rules that I
expect her to follow them but even if
she doesn't I will still love her and I
won't leave her again she says she's
gonna try but she won't promise because
apparently annoying me is very fun I
called her mom and as I expected she has
no problem with this and is willing to
let her live with me so is he an [ __ ]
for telling his kid there's one
condition she has to follow my rules and
be respectful no
I don't think I don't think so but I
think I mean I feel like that was an
important first step is to find out why
yeah before but I don't feel like it was
an unreasonable thing like I think
that's the thing that parents always
especially if he's already having issues
with her to begin with I feel like and
then she's saying it's fun to annoy him
yeah she knows what she's doing but you
put like a little smiley face up for
that so I'm really surprised because the
top answer is oh gosh you're the [ __ ]
I think you're trying to do what you
think is best but I agree with your mom
your 10 year old daughter living with
you shouldn't be conditional if it works
for everyone you say yes then work on
communication discipline you're not the
only one who has to learn she does too
if she had no discipline whatsoever
she'll be stepping into a whole
different world it might be difficult to
adjust she's just a kid who hasn't had
the best or fairest Life by the sounds
of things you possibly hurt her and let
her down thinking that all you care
about and that's all you care about and
just that you don't want trouble
hmm like too much to deal with yeah I'm
I'm very surprised because why am I not
seeing that he's an easy way to I okay
that is a that is one way to take it I
guess I I wouldn't have
taken it that way like as an outside
Observer that he's the [ __ ] like I
never thought of that perspective but
now hearing this person say that
I guess if I had maybe grown up in a
different situation where I didn't feel
like unconditionally like that no matter
what my dad would always be there for
like because I had that my mom wasn't
there for me but my dad no matter what
100 didn't matter what I did he was
always going to be there for me always
going to take care of me so that didn't
occur to me as a thing I took that as
like that's his way of saying you got to
follow the rules yeah but I guess if
there's a situation where
you don't necessarily know if your dad
loves you because he's kind of not
really been there or I guess his own or
his own mom referred to him as deadbeat
dad or whatever yeah he referred to him
as his own mom yeah so like I guess if
you're a kid and you don't really know
like does my dad even want me I don't
know and then he's like well only if
you're gonna follow my rules but if
you're not gonna follow my rules I don't
want you around I guess I can kind of
see but I don't necessarily think he did
that on purpose yeah I think he's just
like you like if you're gonna come live
with me there's gonna be rules like I
think that's what he was trying to get
across not that I don't love you if you
don't follow him you can't live here if
you're not falling yeah I think it was
kind of like he's just trying to figure
out like because he's not been a good
dad so far he's trying to figure out how
to say like hey if if I'm gonna be your
dad I'm going to be your dad you gotta
actually listen to me and I'll just walk
out the door you know like so apparently
people are reading it as you made a
condition that sounded like if you don't
obey the rules I'll kick you out again
yeah like you're just gonna come back
yeah it actually seems like it that's
what it seems like and that's how she's
receiving it I understand that yeah I
think he probably worded this a little
bit different
all right a little bit wrong I guess I
didn't see it like that I I thought it
was just going to be like a general rule
like you have to you know yeah I didn't
see it as conditional I just saw it as
like well once you're here you have to
follow my rules yeah like I think but
then we could reworded it yeah like on
one condition yeah yeah and if this
isn't the condition that you're agreeing
to but that didn't really seem like a
real condition to me like I didn't read
that as like
if she doesn't she's literally going
back to her mom yeah like I just took
that as like that's how you talk to kids
like oh you better you know yeah better
follow my rules yeah because currently
you're not
yeah I wouldn't call him an [ __ ] I
think he's just not very aware yeah he's
just he wasn't communicating that in the
best way for her to feel safe
that was it
she's trying he's trying yeah you know I
don't know he just worded things wrong
no one tells you how to be the perfect
father and obviously he's not he's made
some missteps along the way but at least
he's trying now I'm willing to take her
in so that's okay what's your summer
fantasy a whirlwind romance in Italy
getting wet dancing in a warm rainstorm
or maybe an unexpected Summer Fling no
matter how you want to get steamy this
season Dipsy has a sexy story for you to
indulge in all of your fantasies Dipsy
is an app full of hundreds of short sexy
audio stories designed by women for
women they bring scenarios to life with
immersive soundscapes and characters no
matter who you're into or what turns you
on find stories about that intriguing
co-worker with a British accent or
hooking up with your hot yoga instructor
new content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore Dipsy also
has sleep stories Wellness sessions and
now they also offer written stories it's
your go-to place to spice a of your me
time explore your fantasies or heat
things up with a partner for listeners
of the show dipsy's offering an extended
30-day free trial when you go to
dipsystories.com mood that's 30 days of
full access for free when you go to d i
p s e a stories.com mood
dipsystories.com mood okay so when I was
a kid I had my ears pierced and we went
to a random store until this day my ear
piercing is actually crooked if you
don't want that to happen to you and
want a more safe and accurate piercing
uh then check out studs studs is
reimagining the piercing experience for
each and every ear if you want to
refresh your look with a new piercing or
need Pro styling advice for your ear
check out studs shop online or stop into
studs in La New York City Austin
Nashville Miami Boston Seattle and more
locations coming soon I want to get a
new or evening first time piercing but
feeling a little scared fear not studs
only pierces with single-use needles
never guns so it's way safer and better
especially for advanced piercings studs
earrings are made from high quality
materials which won't turn your skin
green plus they're lightweight and
durable enough to wear all the time you
can even sleep and work out in them
studs has over 250 styles of Hoops
Huggies studs cuffs and dangles and they
pierce way more than just lobes so it's
easy to create a statement look or
something you keep in every day starting
at just ten dollars per earring for the
longest time I've always kind of wanted
to change up my piercing look on my ear
because I literally just have one boring
piercing and I want to change it up a
little bit especially now that I know
that I can get it done proper and
straight right now studs is offering our
listeners 20 off your first purchase
when you go to
www.studs.com big mood go to studs.com
big mood for 20 off your first purchase
once again that's studs.com big mood
next one is am I the [ __ ] for telling
my date that he shouldn't call himself a
Harvard alumnus
oh I think I'm gonna like this one
so I a 25 year old female match with a
guy who had Harvard alum in his bio okay
there aren't too many of those in my
small Midwestern City so I suggest that
we grab some coffee the date started off
wonderfully I can kind of guess what's
happening he had many shared interests
and I want to hear your guess
either he went to some like online
certificate program that was hosted by
Harvard
or it's just too [ __ ] cringy and he
needs to stop like making that his whole
personality one of the two situations
probably the date started off
wonderfully he hadn't met or we had many
shared interests and spent a good 30
minutes talking about them I started
talking about my amazing undergraduate
experience at Harvard and asked him what
he concentrated in he gave me a Blank
Stare after mommy said oh I finished a
web dev certificate from the extension
program
after some Googling I discovered that
anyone can finish the web dev
certificate by paying a six thousand
dollars what is this web development
yeah so it's just like some stupid
little upskilling thing you can put on
your resume or whatever but you didn't
go to Harvard yeah
um so anyone can get that certificate by
paying a six thousand dollar fee and
taking three online courses that's a lot
of money I then asked him not it's like
a semester of school for a certificate I
know but for just a certificate like
just to even I guess it's a lot of money
for bragging away that you don't even
feel like an intro development so you
can kind of get your foot in the door so
it's kind of like going to college but
you don't really need a whole [ __ ]
thing like
um I then asked him why are you calling
yourself a Harvard alumnus when people
hear
Bobby went to Harvard they assumed that
Bobby has an actual degree from Harvard
not some certificate that holds no real
weight
anyway
you wrote this this was mine
he got up and left but not before saying
this is why most people can't stand
people like you
I've gone over our conversation multiple
times yet I can't see where I said
anything wrong she told the truth I mean
I'm on her side
it is corny to put that on your profile
though dude like so I have a kind of a
similar story so I matched with a guy
not really similar
just in the same wheelhouse so I matched
with the guy and we went on our first
date and I thought he was fine enough to
put like to go on a second date I was
like okay you're making it past all my
[ __ ] ridiculous amount of filters so
that's fine I'll I'll go on a second
date with you and then
um I was trying to recall like I was
like where do you go to school at and
then I like kind of looked at his
profile again because I was just kind of
telling my friends I was like oh I think
I met this guy maybe your boyfriend will
like him and like we can double date or
something he's into sports blah blah
blah and then there said something about
like where did you go to school or
something so I was like I [ __ ] for
God and then I looked at his profile
again because I like always take
screenshots like just in case like if I
want to pull it up you know um to refer
to what they said like because sometimes
I feel like that's how you can catch
people in a lie too is like screenshot
their profile that way like if they
later change it yeah or something like I
you know so then I looked and said okay
bachelor's degree something whatever
whatever but it didn't say from where so
I was like oh remind me where you went
to school at because I'm like trying to
see um my friend is interested in what
kind of college football you like like
maybe you guys will follow the same team
or something we can all go out together
and he's like oh I didn't finish school
um and I was like huh did you lie about
going to school then because your
profile says bachelor's degree and like
that's kind of also that's like a thing
that I do to weed people out because I'm
like I have a [ __ ] master's degree in
a state like I'm licensed by the state
and all this [ __ ] and I feel like I just
want someone also educated like shoot me
for being [ __ ] particular about that
so like I use that as one of my filters
and then he was like oh no I didn't
finish school I just like
was trying to say that I like started
school I but I don't have a degree I
didn't realize that that the thing says
bachelor's degree
and then it came out I said that on a
profile and so I was just like ew like
I'm like bro it says you have a
bachelor's degree are you like kind of
break like bending the [ __ ] yeah you
know acting stupid about it too yeah he
was like I didn't know it was on there I
didn't know it read that way
what did you expect I'm like I [ __ ]
sent him a screenshot like he says
bachelor's degree on your [ __ ]
profile like
you just started school and didn't
finish but you still think it's
appropriate like just don't put your
school in there at all like you're
bending you're like kind of lying a
little bit to like make it through
people like me who have filters set for
degrees right yeah it's ridiculous
that's weird so yeah I feel like and if
he was gonna lie about that on his
profile you couldn't like come up with
like [ __ ] further ride I think the
thing is like they think right I think
they could well I don't care where you
go to school right it's just like I I
feel like at some point mentally if
you've gone through so much level of
Education like you're gonna
want someone that's also gone through
that much level of Education like to be
your partner because like there's just a
different mindset and different ways of
thinking and like like you can get into
arguments or like one person can feel
like less than or or have like a like
some sort of um they what's the word I'm
thinking of insecurity like if I have
all the like all these degrees and
license all this stuff and then he's
just like he went to high school it's
like I feel like it's not gonna match
like he's gonna probably a lot of times
the guys are gonna be a little bit feel
like resentful about that so I'm just
like I'm not gonna deal with that [ __ ]
like I want us to both be educated and
so the fact that I feel like he thinks
that if he can just get through my
filter he'll win me over kind of thing
and it should let it slide you know like
I'm not gonna I'm not the let it slide
kind of person like you and I'm sure
everyone tells Little White Lies like
I'm sure there's something I've told a
little white lie about here there before
but it's just like that just bothers me
because it's like why are you trying to
be something you're not yeah yeah
if he's lying about that he couldn't
come up with put the further lie to like
complete it like to be like I went to
school here and did this like at least
no he just like I I just think that he
felt like he needed like this like the
in the he needed an in and he felt like
because he had a good job now that
didn't require a degree that that it
would be fine that he had a kind of
lighted to get through the filter system
but it's like I'm not lying to get
through anyone this major process he's
like a director of like a like a medical
center or something and I'm like fine
you worked your way in a different way I
don't care if you have a degree why do
you have to for example why you gotta be
fake about [ __ ] like it's embarrassing
yeah like that's embarrassing for you
that you're lying about [ __ ] like that
you know like I don't know is that like
also in the beginning it's like what if
you're like oh I'm so excited about this
guy um and you describe him to your
friends like he's well he has a
bachelor's degree he went to this
University or whatever
yeah like at the same time it's like
that doesn't [ __ ] matter just don't
like it doesn't [ __ ] really it
doesn't [ __ ] matter necessarily like
but like typically as I'm dating like I
am like kind of trying to find someone
who is equal to me you know what I mean
so it's just like I don't know
uh top comment says everyone sucks here
but babe what you seriously sat across
from this person and googled this [ __ ]
while he was sitting across from you
wait she Googled it yeah she said yeah
she said
um let me see I thought she just asked
no she said it was just the now after
that moment he said oh uh uh after some
Googling I discovered that anyone can
finish that and then so I asked him why
are you calling yourself a Harvard
alumnus so she did it while he was
sitting in front of her that's funny
wait how did she do that I missed it or
something okay so he said it was just a
certificate well she's seven at the date
she said I started talking about my
amazing undergraduate experience at
Harvard and asked him what he
concentrated in he gave me a blank stare
and said oh I finished a web development
certificate from the extension program
to Google that like I already know that
that's yeah no I think they do that
everywhere I think she wanted to google
like the qualifications to even get that
certificate and that's what she was like
anyone could just get this yeah you
didn't do a hard way of getting accepted
yeah like the way she did because well
she's also kind of dumb because
literally I can go to UCLA and get like
a business certificate for like this or
that like anyone could do that at any
school
including Harvard especially if she went
to Harvard yeah you would think that
she'd be smart enough to know that
there's these certificates are available
for purchase
um second comment says
everyone sucks here but frankly iconic
on both sides exactly I love the lying
love looking the guys lie up right in
front of him you two would really be fun
to watch in a sitcom I don't want to
know either of you in real life no no
um no yeah okay I totally missed the
Googling at the table because that
awkward yeah but I would I would be the
person though that would be like wait so
you didn't go to Harvard yeah
um same person says uh yeah you're an
[ __ ] not for Googling not for
Googling it although you're on a date so
if you want to know more about the
person's certificate maybe later ask but
you are an [ __ ] for belittling the
guy's education he shouldn't have lied
but telling him his certificate carries
no real weight after a quick Google
search is really really mean telling him
I'm not sure if that makes you an Alum
and changing the subject is normal uh
telling him that and leaving that as it
is is fine tell him that a certificate
is meaningless is deeply unkind yeah I
mean she didn't have to say it was
meaningless yeah
but I think I mean the fact that she
said
it's meaningless yeah she told him it
carries no weight she's like you should
call yourself an alum for something that
you caught online that carries no weight
okay I mean that is a little it's kind
of I think I think I would have it's
definitely like the sitcom version of
like going all the way I think it would
have just been more like oh okay so you
really didn't go to Harvard though or
like like it would be like hey man what
you doing with this fake you know it's
like it's like um like when people uh
wear Marine [ __ ] outfits like seven
dollars yeah it's like
yeah yeah I'm like Stolen Valor is
cringy as [ __ ] and same thing like
pretending to be something you're not as
cringy as [ __ ] like so I would have to
be like so you're not really that right
like
it's ridiculous um this comment says not
the [ __ ] he wasn't exactly lying but
he sure was exaggerating he just pointed
it out like I was injured in Navy boot
camp and got medically discharged back
when I was 18 and it would be like me
calling myself a Navy that which I
definitely do not do if you fell during
boot camp you didn't really earn yeah
you know the title of Veteran you didn't
go anywhere yeah
um not the [ __ ] something very
similar happened to me a guy said in his
body that he went and studied at
Cambridge in the UK I studied there
myself so so I was trying to use that as
a way to strike up a conversation ask
them in which or asked him in which
college he studied Etc he got very
offended saying he only mentioned
Cambridge University as a joke question
mark what and he didn't want to date
pretentious snob like me what oh that's
the same thing
they're just trying to use like some
[ __ ] title to get dumb girls to
sleep with him and so like calling them
out across from the table to me honestly
I don't care because it's like
fraudulent fishing and it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's like if you think that
women are so [ __ ] dumb then all you
gotta do is say I went to Harvard and
then they'll be sucking all over your
dick well you might catch one or two
little guppies but guess what someone's
gonna [ __ ] say you cry across table
from you one day and be like you didn't
actually go to Harvard Sweeney oh this
is really interesting
um everyone sucks here technically he is
a car or he is a Harvard Extension
school alumnus so he isn't necessarily
wrong it is wrong extension hold on well
not a Harvard College Central degree
holder the extension school is indeed a
part of Harvard and the courses are
taught by Harvard faculty you can even
earn them you can't go for a day hold on
you can even earn a full degree through
the extension school programs they
aren't solely certificate programs it's
meant to encourage learning and make
Harvard accessible to non-traditional
students first gen International or even
students that can't live in the area I
work at Harvard which is why I know this
your delivery may have come across quite
harsh with the no real wait comment
um that that was inaccurate and
judgmental you could have just said
something like oh okay the extension
school I mistook that for Harvard
College which is where I did my
undergrad can you tell me more about
what the extension School experience is
like that way you wouldn't be putting
them down but instead of getting to know
him better no this is some liberal
[ __ ] you know
you don't know his life situation he
didn't go to Harvard okay stop [ __ ]
trying to make excuses for him using
stolen Harvard Valor he didn't go he
can't sit with us and then someone
someone argued saying I think the issue
is not that he went to extension school
and got a certificate but that the
certificate isn't considered a grant to
Grant Alum status if I put that [ __ ] on
your profile yeah if you want to add
that to the date and be like you know I
actually did a did an extension
certificate like at Harvard and it was
pretty cool I got to learn from some
Harvard yeah
like [ __ ] people do that [ __ ] like
it's so cringy too like so in my uh
field in accounting there's like four
companies that are really big like
worldwide companies and a lot of people
try to get into those right out of
college and so they'll be like kids that
just graduated from college who just got
an offer letter from like and so they're
like future so and so associate and it's
like so cringy it's just like but you
haven't even done anything yet like it's
so stupid I don't know oh good okay oh
yeah I think that response was perfect
though because that wasn't his intention
to come off yeah like hey you know I
don't know what he was doing he knew he
was doing that's exactly why he
responded the way he did too where it's
like yeah that's why you your people are
that's why that's why people don't like
you yeah exactly people like you don't
[ __ ] have a hard time
is she an [ __ ] or not
yeah
she wasn't she's an [ __ ] but it's
deserved yes because it's Justified
[ __ ] yeah again it's kind of deserved
like it was a mean thing to say but he
kind of deserved it yeah you know what
he was doing
what the definition of [ __ ] in this
situation because you can still be an
[ __ ] but be right you know like you
you are an [ __ ] but you are right why
is she an [ __ ] if he's a liar why is
she an ass mom the way she delivered she
didn't have to be why do you have to be
nice to Liars
I feel like treating the the humanity in
the person with compassion yeah you have
to be nice to the liar inside of
everyone apparently because I I
subscribe to your thoughts but I
understand what they're saying if
someone comes at me that's the right
thing with Miss intention why do I have
to coddle them is all I'm saying yeah
I'm an [ __ ] when they are coming at
me with good intentions and I [ __ ] go
down their throat yeah that's to me what
an [ __ ] is that's exactly what I
believe so that's why I'm struggling
with the definition of [ __ ]
was it mean it gets me in trouble so
many times Maybe
all right let me see
um
next one is am I the [ __ ] for
humiliating my wife on social media to
quote defend my mom oh let's see what
happens I feel like this is definitely
yeah probably
he humiliated his wife yeah on social
media
humiliate his wife
um we have finally gotten no contact
with my mom it was a really long and
hard decision but she and my wife are
just fundamentally unable to get along
and recently had a vicious fight and I
knew I had to put my wife first the
fight was so good husband
the fight was so bad my mom didn't even
protest in no contact
and we are just done with each other but
I can't say it hasn't been gut-wrenching
yeah my mom has given her version of a
story to everyone so I get that my wife
wants to defend herself but I hate that
she's posting on social media because I
find that tacky and my mom just told
people verbally anyways my wife made a
couple posts about my mom's behavior
over the years which hey they were true
but then she claimed my mom wore white
to our wedding she didn't and she posted
a picture to prove it the picture is not
from our wedding though it is from my
mom's own wedding and my wife labeled it
mother and son dance
I was mortified I don't even care about
the white dress that's weird I don't
even care about the white dress but the
man that my mom was dancing with was her
husband not me but the face was cropped
out wow and I felt humiliated he was
holding her very intimately hand on her
lower back her head buried in his chest
my mom and I would never ever touch like
that and it made me feel ick hell my mom
was stiff during the actual mother
Sundance I know some families are very
affectionate but I would never do that I
asked my wife to take it down and she
refused oh come on girl so I took him to
my own hands and comments
and lots of comments saying honey I
think you're confused that's
step dad's name remember that was their
wedding she actually wore green to ours
and posted the pictures for proof my
wife was Furious and deeply hurt she
broke down crying and said I publicly
humili humiliated her and sided with my
mom but she did she did the humiliation
first and also he spoke to her about it
to take it down and like be like girl
why you lying yeah she says she just
wanted a little bit of petty revenge and
I should have taken her side it's been a
day and she's like you were by my side
for the troll yeah
so why would why would he take her side
for the troll when it makes him look
like exactly and then the fact that like
some Oedipus [ __ ] relationships
creepy [ __ ] mom son love [ __ ] bad
photo yeah he's lost it I wonder how he
would have reacted if it wasn't like
such an intimate photo yeah if it was
just like or if it was like a meme like
what if she posted like a meme photo or
something like it wasn't actually then
like she was trying to troll and like
like be an [ __ ] and it was like a
photo of something embarrassing but like
on the internet like a meme thing that
could fit the situation how was she had
gotten away with this anyways because
I'm assuming they would be friends with
his family too and one of those wedding
excuse me no we're here are some
pictures that we took at the wedding we
were all there yeah what a weird life
she's not good at this is she a drunk is
she like it's a wine o'clock somewhere
right got a wife oh my God a whiny wife
so she's a whino like how are they gonna
lie about something that hundreds of
people attended you know
yes but also first of all very trashy to
be posting all this [ __ ] on Facebook
that's why I deleted Facebook because it
is the Cesspool of society it's fun to
watch though yeah
it's terrible I mean I feel bad for him
that he's like in this situation I don't
think that he's the [ __ ] no I don't
think he's the [ __ ] either because
he's caught in the middle of this
[ __ ] fuse yeah and his wife is being
a [ __ ] dumbass yeah it looks like a
weird photo like yeah that's strange but
like if you have to lie
to to make your own like if you're if
you're telling your side of the story
and like there's like some logs in there
to make yourself feel better I can kind
of get that if she does that but if
you're just making up a whole different
situation
and then it makes your husband look like
a weirdo yeah like you're like dumb wait
even though our lady even the small Lies
Part like for what reason yeah why why
lie I understand like if like people do
that I see being like like oh she missed
the whole [ __ ] first half of the
wedding maybe she was 30 minutes late or
something and you'd be like she missed
the whole [ __ ] half you know like
exaggerations maybe when you're upset as
far as I can give you but to like post a
photo a photo of the wrong makeup
scenario
yeah that's so weird and then no for me
the part that is the most irritating is
the fact that the husband spoke to her
to take it down and she said yeah and
she said that there was gonna be no
consequences yeah
so um comments are saying not the
[ __ ] she publicly humiliated herself
by acting like a little petty teen
engaged in social media smear complaint
campaigns yeah next one's so funny she
sounds unhinged yeah yeah uh not the
[ __ ] your wife is immature for doing
that why would she post such a thing not
considering your feelings about it much
less your mother's even if you guys are
at odds with her she deserves being
called out next time she'll be mindful
of what she posts wife sounds like a
[ __ ] drama queen yeah you know what
he should have posted instead of the
wedding photo
he should have posted the original photo
yeah where the mom wasn't wearing white
when she was wearing green no no the
original
with the guy's face in it like in just a
different angle where you can clearly
see it's like a different guy
um I think this was a different event
there you go oh here's a good comment
wrong about honey uh not the [ __ ] I
hope you went no contact with your mom
based on behavior that you have
witnessed yourself because your wife
clearly doesn't mind lying and
manipulating yeah yeah
good morning
is a great Point yeah maybe the mom's
like dude your [ __ ] wife is batshit
I'm done yeah yeah it's like I tried
saving you from yeah and you don't
listen to me you're You're gone too
normally I'm way too far normally I
would feel like the husband should
always stick up for the wife but if like
if from the outside we can see that
she's [ __ ] batshit crazy
yeah that's [ __ ] wild yeah
[Music]
um okay so everyone is saying that he is
not the [ __ ] and his wife is [ __ ]
crazy yeah yeah I hope he's not being
messy she's messy so that's the kind of
stuff I see on Facebook I'm like
I can't stand that [ __ ] I'm just happy
he's pretty evolved it just makes me
feel like Society is getting worse and I
want to be oblivious to how stupid
people are I don't want to know how
stupid and trashy everyone is I'd rather
pretend like we're all just like nice to
each other civilized civilized sometimes
just car crashes I don't want to I don't
want to watch them
um all right yeah so I don't watch the
news anymore I don't look up anything
it's a mess the only things I do on my
phone is to take pictures and video of
Luca and play my game that's all they do
I have like a little app game I'm like
the world depresses me it does every
time I get updates of what's happening
in the world I'm like I'd rather be in
my bubble in that note we're so thick oh
it's this new shampoo I started using I
hate it what it makes it feel really
like Tangled
um today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easiest way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer now let me tell
you guys I absolutely love online
shopping because you know I'm not trying
to be in a physical store with a crying
infant in my arms no thank you I'd
rather just do all my shopping online
and I love the fact that I have honey
installed in my computer and on my
iPhone because anytime I'm shopping
online honey just pops up and it scours
the internet for coupon codes to use for
whatever site I'm on and it just saves
me so much money like recently I was
shopping for a birthday gift because I
went to a kid's birthday party and it
actually saved me like five dollars on
this kid's birthday present where I'm
like this is amazing and the fact that
it's just online you know I just waited
for it to be delivered to my home and I
did not have to have that hassle of
being in a physical store so the way
honey works is when you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites when you
check out the honey button appears and
all you have to do is just click apply
coupons you wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons you could find for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop just
like I did Honey doesn't just work on a
desktop like I've mentioned it also
works on your iPhone you just activate
it on Safari on your phone and you save
on the go if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show I'd never recommend something that
I don't actually use and trust me guys I
use honey all the time because I'm
always shopping online get honey for
free at joinhoney.com mood that's
joinhoney.com
mood next one am I the [ __ ] for
serving my sister's husband dinner using
toy utensils
no there has to be a reason absolutely
when you cheat a man like a child
let's go I mail so this is just giving
me ideas this is probably not a good
thing for me
I male 17 17 years old moved in with uh
my sister after my parents kicked me out
for coming out another story it's fine
um they said I'll be they said I'll be
here temporarily till I get back to
normal which I don't think I will that
sucks but uh anyways so I moved in with
my sister and her husband about a month
ago FYI she does everything around the
house I started helping here and there
as well as looking after a two-year-old
niece and she now she's six months
pregnant brother-in-law that sounds like
the two-year-old needs a six months
pregnant the way that was right
so I was listening to Nibbler come here
so his sister right hi so the sister
does everything around the house
including taking care of her
two-year-old daughter and she's also six
months pregnant brother-in-law does
nothing because he's the breadwinner as
he claims but in my opinion he's taken
it a bit too far example he tell her to
start his laundry once he takes off his
clothes puts it on the table once he's
home get the shower ready and so on
his shower ready jeez you can't turn the
[ __ ] faucet on no what does that even
mean get it ready like you want all the
hot water to be gone by the time you get
in true or maybe it takes a while to
heat up he wants it to no or this is El
Rancho and she has to go heat up the
[ __ ] oh yeah of water like what the
[ __ ]
um they fight a lot because my sister is
exhausted and burnt out I usually put on
my headphones and mind my own business
but two nights ago there was a lot of
commotion once he got home so I went to
see what the issue was turns out
brother-in-law was complaining about
dinner and my sister was too exhausted
to get up I mean the dinner was already
cooked but he wanted her to put it for
him on the table
this is like an old ass asian family
like what the [ __ ] we're Hispanic
that's like super
machismo I mean the dinner was already
cooked but he wanted her to put it in
front of him on the table I told myself
he's been watching Andrew Tate oh yeah
yeah really that's what he preaches
probably yeah his Dick's probably small
then
um I told my sister I'd do it but
instead of using their kitchen utensils
I use my niece's toy utensils like toy
cup toys or he did it yeah he did it the
brothers that's funny yeah toy review
pork and knife and a tiny napkin
yeah it's like a little triangle napkin
I put the food on the toy plate and the
drink in the sippy cup while my
brother-in-law was in the shower he then
came into the kitchen and sat down and
stared at the plate for a few seconds he
then looked at me and asked what the
hell was this and whether I was joking I
told him if he wanted to act like a
helpless child then he might as well get
treated like one
again yelling and my sister came inside
he then threw the napkin and stormed off
saying that eyes
oh this man is a small small ego
um he threw the napkin and stormed off
saying that I disrespected him and that
he'll let my parents know about what I
did my sister saw what I'd done and
started laughing that's amazing I
wouldn't set my room but the argument
didn't stop and now he's expecting an
apology for me for meddling in his
marriage and pulling this crappy stunt
on him way I could be the [ __ ] for
this but I was just so mad for my sister
and also so sick and tired of being sick
and tired of the nightly fighting over
dinner am I the [ __ ] no that's
hilarious that's [ __ ] funny so y'all
took this guy's side saying he's not an
[ __ ] how come well who's it I didn't
respond you said no he's not an [ __ ]
she did no there's probably a more
tactful way he could have done it okay
but like the whole like Ultra machismo
shut the [ __ ] up that's my answer to all
the other ones that I said yeah that's
true I'm like when is it he was still my
vote is he was a Justified [ __ ] I
think it's because I didn't hit the
middle I have experience with this my
grandfather was such a [ __ ] like
tyrant
that he would
um like whenever he had like his friends
over he would do like a it's like a show
of power right like all the aunts and
stuff have to or all everyone has to
listen to him because he's ahead of the
house and
so everyone's like kind of catering him
serving to him I'm upstairs doing my
homework and then all of a sudden you
hear screaming Jada I was like 10 years
old and I came downstairs like yes he
goes give me that cup right there and I
was like what like because his friends
while everyone's like give me that cup
right there it was like well then Arm's
Reach of him and then so I handed it to
him so I was like what the [ __ ] was that
yeah or like you know so he always did
that or he always demanded like
um when he went back to Vietnam to visit
his in-laws he demanded everyone else to
sit in another room while they're eating
dinner because this is a table for the
important people the men of the house
yeah he was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] so
this is where it kind of hits close to
home and like
if I can serve him baby food and stuff
like that I would love that
so be creative for 17 year olds you'd
just be like family teaches grown-ups in
one way it's like you're an [ __ ]
because these people are taking you in
but another way it's like it's pretty
funny yeah it's pretty funny that's why
I said he's a Justified [ __ ] because
he didn't have to be meddling yes it's
infuriating to see your sister go
through that but that is her marriage
you don't need to participate but it is
funny though yeah but yeah it's it's not
your problem but it is funny and plus I
can I could see him wanting to defend
his sister yeah you know I think he's an
[ __ ] so maybe not an [ __ ] but it's
like how about a good like a good
[ __ ] like we were saying earlier yeah
people are feeding you and letting you
stay but it was funny and I understand
it but also like I don't know it's like
men have to check each other and even
though this is a 17 year old
he's still more of a man than the other
one so it's almost like how do you check
his behavior which is completely [ __ ]
unacceptable this machismo [ __ ]
controlling-ass [ __ ] in a more calm
way than to be like hey you're acting
like a child look I'm gonna serve you
like a child like that's how you check
someone's [ __ ] Behavior by proving a
point I bet if it was the other way
around and she was suddenly The
Breadwinner and she demanded this from
him he would be like no yeah
for sure I don't think they wouldn't
stay together no there's no way he would
handle it was so fragile yeah no way
um top comment is okay so this is funny
as hell and he totally had it coming but
we all know you should have stayed way
out of this LOL though I get that you
were trying to stick up for your sister
who deserve who does deserve that please
accept my softest it or everyone sucks
here
you might have actually made them fight
more abuse of people like your
brother-in-law often take these things
out on people like your sister that's
true that's true so then at that point
it's like they need to not be together
if you can't [ __ ] clown on this guy
and he's gonna go now beat your sister
then this is a bigger this is a
different topic you know what I mean
yeah
uh second top comment not the [ __ ]
this guy sounds like a super
misogynistic [ __ ] good for you for
standing up for your sister
uh next one says yeah the fact that the
sister was laughing I wonder if the
husband saw that yeah right or if she
was just laughing like this in her head
it's like a better noise
oh
you know what I'm saying he deserves to
be checked and he does
um another comment says although I
commend you for what you did LMAO
everyone sucks here because most likely
the repercussions will fall on your
sister what so [ __ ] no that's not the
[ __ ] that's not that thing though
it's like if if she's gonna get in
trouble for that that relationship does
not need to be happening yeah you don't
[ __ ] go take [ __ ] out on your sister
because your [ __ ] brother made a joke
checking you for your behavior on your
wife yeah not the [ __ ] the husband
sounds like he needs a nap too yes it
might be a burping
but basically everyone's saying I
strongly approve however unfortunately
it's not accomplished a thing and more
likely than not your sister will suffer
from it they will argue whatever again
and yeah that would suck but I
understand why he did it and it was
hilarious but it sucks that the dude
like that dude just sucks yeah yeah that
does suck but it is pretty funny I wish
I would have seen that face for two
seconds right nothing to me justifies if
I have an issue with someone else I'm
gonna now take it out on you yeah but
then these people are misogynistic the
misogynistic [ __ ] and they're
abusers so they don't care because
they're not gonna take it out on someone
else because they're too much of little
[ __ ] ever fight a man right so they
don't know how to control their anger so
yeah I don't know why everyone's like
piling on him like oh you shouldn't have
done that now he's gonna beat her it's
like uh no like maybe you should have
done more and [ __ ] try to help figure
out the situation where we can maybe
she's get away from him but she's not
gonna get away from him unless she
decides for herself there's a lot of I
know but like instead of being like Oh
you're an [ __ ] now he's gonna beat
her it's like be like oh hey this if
this situation is actually that bad
let's figure out a way that you can help
your sister see see how she can get out
of this yeah but I don't think that's
like the topic it's more like am I the
[ __ ] for this that's all I don't
think so no no and everyone being like
Oh now he's gonna beat her it's like
wait what we're missing the [ __ ]
interviewing but I'm just saying like
for example take it out on her and it
will further arguing or like you know
just like because of what he did it's
her fault like this is a bigger problem
I could see that being an argument where
it's like he's your brother why aren't
you controlling your brother how's he
gonna come into my house disrespect me
when we're bringing him in that could be
it yeah she's like and then she would
have to argue for the brother to stay
you know so now there's a whole new
argument of arguing if like if the
brother should stay or not so it added
to the problem you know like a whole new
topic now so well then he just kicked
himself in the in the asset yeah like
because he disrespected the
the person who's letting him stay there
yeah but yeah I mean this is not a good
situation yeah so the next one is
am I the [ __ ] for asking my son and
daughter-in-law for a copy of the key to
the to the new house they bought
okay well depends on how much you're
thinking you're gonna use that key yeah
and why so two weeks ago my son Ethan 27
years old and his wife Jess uh oh 30
years old bought a younger younger man
um but a small one-story house in a town
we live in after settling down they
invited us over for a small party for
the occasion
we sat for dinner and talked about the
house a bit me my husband and Jess
continued conversing while Ethan excused
himself to take an important call Jess
showed me the original key to the house
and asked if she made copies if and I
asked if she made copies yet and she
said no I said she should and also give
one to me as well she looked at me funny
and asked why
um I explained that it is necessary so
that it could be used in emergencies she
Ridley said I don't know what kind of an
emergency that would require you having
a key to our house sure won't be a fire
incident
I don't know what that means but um but
yeah basically I don't know what kind of
emergency would require you having a key
to our house yeah okay she obviously
didn't seem to have any idea that a fire
incident wasn't what I meant and I got
offended by her sarcasm I pointed out
that it's not just her decision because
this is my son's house as well she
smiled at me trying to be polite and
stated that only the ones who
contributed towards a house gets a copy
of the key and that I really don't need
one anyways also assured me that my son
will have the same answer as me
basically saying don't bother bringing
this up with Ethan he'll tell you the
same thing but I did and she spoke on
his behalf the entire argument repeating
what she said over and over things
escalated to her calling me pushy and me
telling her she was being unnecessarily
rude and disrespectful
my husband and I left in a rush and I
felt horrible my husband went on and on
about how paranoid and controlling I was
to basically be quote demanding a copy
of the key to the new house but again I
stated that I was just trying to be
helpful and taking extra precautions
since anything can happen but he
insisted I overstepped and ruined
Ethan's and Justice joy for the new
house as well as dinner I genuinely do
not think that I was out of line and I'm
not sure why I just reacted so intensely
I think my request was innocent
ah
I feel like I understand where she's
coming from but she's not very aware of
the fact that like
she has to let go a little bit more of
her son and like give the the space part
to be the woman of the house and make
that decision it's like why does she
still think she's the mom yeah who has
to like be able to check in yeah we're
gonna find [ __ ] like her in the
kitchen one day like and then the wife's
gonna be like naked and be like what the
what are you what are you doing yeah
like I get where she's coming from like
she just can't get out of mom mind where
she's like oh something could happen
like I need to make sure I can get in
there if something would happen yeah I
feel like the way she requested it came
off very entitled and that rubbed the
wife the wrong way where it's like
[ __ ] is my house yeah like who do you
see why do you think you're the head of
this house yeah exactly so I feel like
if she had a better approach
that entire argument could have been
avoided but also it sounds like
the wife probably has already dealt with
her overstepping a lot where this was
kind of like the last straw for her was
like no [ __ ] this is my house you're
not gonna get a [ __ ] key to my house
you're not gonna overstep your your [ __ ]
over here this is my [ __ ] house I
think that's what happened because then
the way because yeah it makes sense like
you clearly want to have there's no
trust exactly yeah like you want a a key
to your house to someone you trust in
case of an emergency she's correct but
the way that it was so entitled and also
you can sense that there's history with
that with how quickly the wife got
offended by what the mom said yeah
because I would probably give my key to
like one of y'all because like I know
that you wouldn't just come yeah Gina
you might just come in and be napping in
my bed one day I don't know but like but
like I you know like I it's easy to give
your key to someone where you're like
they're not gonna use it like they don't
really want to [ __ ] yeah over here
yeah like they have no reason to come
over here so maybe if it was like they
had a better relationship and the mom
was like oh you should you know you
should drop off a copy of the key if you
want you know yeah we could have a copy
of the key if you ever need it and then
just never [ __ ] bring it up again and
let the wife decide if she's comfortable
with that you know like because I could
foresee something and maybe if they have
a baby for sure like maybe but like
right now it's like she's so on top of
this like I need your key right now yeah
like too much even her own husband was
like girl yeah you're doing too much
yeah it does seem like there's history
here because I would give my key to my
dad you know yes I know I would never
[ __ ] come to my house like he's never
coming over yeah so I think there is
history here where she's overstepped a
lot yeah but yeah like the way she
brought it up was like what did you make
a copy why not you know it's weird it's
like really entitled yeah like at the
[ __ ] party they just moved in like
where's my puppy yeah exactly yeah so
entitled that's a lot it was brought up
more like
um if you guys want you guys can yeah
like you can just give me yeah and then
if there's any emergency I can stop by
that's it but yeah
to be willing to run an errand if
something needs to be done or also like
oh yeah you know you have a key to my
house in case there's an emergency yeah
something else you know like they're a
married couple of kids I'm like here
just take your key just in case I
haven't even used it yeah no we we
exchanged keys with our close neighbors
and it's really handy because they help
us take care of our kitties when we're
gone and then I help take care of it
they're like hey I'm gonna be out of
town for like three weeks can you move
some packages from this yeah we do that
for each other all the time yeah yeah
because you know like there's trust
there where you're like I know that
they're not gonna like be weird about it
yeah
um Mama over there is probably gonna be
weird about it yeah top comment is you
are the [ __ ] it's all about phrasing
do people offer copies of their keys to
trusted family members in case of
anything yes definitely the key word is
offer though yeah
you said to two adults you need to give
me a copy of your key which is why
you're the [ __ ] yeah and then you
double down by continuing to push even
if they said or even if you had said hey
if you want us to keep a copy of your
key for emergencies that's fine and then
left a little alone yeah so phrasing and
also probably tone exactly in history
like Tiff said she already knows she
doesn't want that key given to her
mother-in-law she's like I have
a college friend who I haven't talked to
in 10 years that I would give a key to
right over you yeah exactly she's like
we've got friends
yeah
the second comment says you sound like
one of those overbearing mother-in-laws
you had a point about someone having a
key but that doesn't or that someone
didn't have to be you and you should
have talked to them sooner you should
have dropped it once she said no but
instead you pulled the it's my son's
house too yikes and made up that's what
makes you feel like there's deep history
yeah like there's history
um like I feel like she's one of those
moms that's like like she's taking care
of the grandkid and the the uh the wife
is like don't feed him peanut butter
well I'm gonna ask my son and if he says
my son can have that that grandson can
have peanut butter then that's fine like
she's one of those like goes behind your
back and yeah oversteps her boundaries
kind of people like your wife is just uh
just the birthing center and like this
is my grandbaby yeah
um
and you made a power play for your son
and which woman he'd listen to which is
weird and unnecessary then you got
offended and had to make a scene your
son is married and he has a new priority
now never alone yep I'm glad these
commenters told her yeah God I can't
imagine having a mom like that
um you're the [ __ ] it's their house
and their choice who gets Keys when she
said no the first time you should have
dropped it your husband and Jess are
right you're being pushy and controlling
and that behavior ruined dinner I'm
actually kind of curious to see if her
name's Judy
um okay so Judy did reply to a few
things how do you see that I just go
through your profile and go to comments
that they've left
um okay only teach me how to read it
where is it but she's like yes the main
concern is safety and that was the
reason I asked just doesn't have family
here we're usually in good terms till a
few months ago when she stopped visiting
with my son no idea why oh my God she's
so awesome don't worry there's no
self-awareness oh my God ah that is the
white lady curse
oh god well oh we agree she's the
[ __ ] yeah like that I hope not I
don't hope I hope I don't marry into a
family like that
um I think that's it yeah yeah all right
yeah that's all the time hope you guys
enjoyed this episode let us know below
if you guys disagree with us I mean you
can you're probably stupid but
I want to hear it I will accept no
disagreements I am always right always
am I the [ __ ]
but thanks for watching and uh let us
know what you guys think in the comments
give us your opinion yeah check out our
sponsors down below and um make sure you
like subscribe give us a thumbs up we
love you peace out be good don't be an
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]